Justin Bieber shows off his massive new  tattoo the 23 year old singer took to  social media on Saturday to share the  fresh ink which covers the majority of  his torso man justin is clearly a fan of  his new artwork posting this video  flaunting the huge tat his fans on the  other hand were quick to go crazy one  believer tweeted these old photos of  Bieber's abs pre tattoos lamenting I  never thought I'd miss this view until  now another row rest in peace Justin's  beautiful chest you will be missed  and this believer hilariously tweeted a  Taylor Swift reference I'm sorry the old  Justin Bieber can't come to the phone  right now  why oh because he's dead what should we  need to  you